what's going on everybody welcome to a
bit of an update video
people have been asking from comments
and emails and tweets and then discord
um mostly where's part six but also are
you alive
so uh yes i am alive i'm doing well uh
some of you might know my wife
is a physician she has coveted patients
um but
uh she and she was even in quarantine
for a little bit but uh we know we're do
we're both doing okay
and uh yeah no no problem there just
been
really busy and you know 2020 has just
been
a crazy year i mean obviously the covid
stuff
um i am still engaged in suing udemy for
copyright infringement
i am um my dog got heartworm i'm
actually going to pick her up later
today from the vet
um and we do treat we treat all of our
dogs so it's very odd that my dog would
get heartworm but anyway
that's beside the point um and yeah just
just covet and just 20 20. like what a
strange year
this has has been um but
uh the the main suck of of my time has
been the neural networks from scratch
book we are just
trying to get that done um you know when
i
made the projection of august 2020 uh
covid really hadn't happened yet
so that was like a in a distant land of
china and now it is
obviously here in full force so um yeah
we're just doing everything we can to
kind of meet that meet that goal i i
suspect we're going to wind up pushing
that from
august uh so if you bought from nnfs.io
the projected date was september 2020
um that's that's i think that's doable
still
but there are lots of little piddly
things like right now i'm working on
formatting the book well i got to format
the book kind of twice there's a
you know an epub or a you know an
e-reader version of the book
and then there's going to obviously be
the print version of the book and then
those kind of
have different ish requirements you know
little stuff that you probably don't
really think that much about but you
know you know the page number of the
left page should be bottom left and the
page number on the right page should be
bottom right and
things like that and then um like
building out the index for example
you know all these little things they
just add up and then obviously the
images the animations
and like the animations for the book if
you didn't know we have like little qr
codes so you can scan those and that
links you to
a youtube uh video of the animation so
anyway we're just
we're doing all those things and just
trying to kind of wrap everything up but
the entire
first draft of the book is done
so if you have access or if you've
purchased the book in any form the
e-book all the way up to hardcover
you should have access if you don't uh
email me there's still probably
uh like 100 or 200 people that
aren't in the uh ebook or aren't in the
google doc
so uh if that's you maybe you're just
waiting for the book and that's i guess
that's fine
um but if you think you should have
access let me know and that brings me to
the second point that we have sold over
3 000
copies um or pre-sold over 3 000 copies
which is
uh incredible uh so yeah that's just
been
really really cool so i get it i know
you guys are itching for part six i know
a lot of people are stuck at home
and all that i totally understand right
now our focus is on the book if you can
i understand not everybody can afford to
buy the book but if you can there that's
where you could get the content right
now
i wish we could be doing the videos in
the book at the same time it's just
the videos are taking way longer to
produce than
i thought they would um and because the
book has
a deadline of some sort um that's that's
what's going to take priority
the good news is we will continue we
will continue pushing the neural
networks from scratch videos
it's just we're going to have to hold
those off until we're
really printing the book and then we can
go back to those videos so they will
come
it just will take some time um and yes i
am alive
so uh anyway just a quick update of kind
of all the things that are
are going on uh in this this crazy crazy
world i hope you guys are all
doing okay and thank you to everyone who
has supported this book i
uh this is by far the videos are the
best videos that
that we have ever made and by we are
really me and daniel
it's an equal effort that's going into
these videos so um
if you're not aware of daniel he's the
one that does like the animations for
the the videos for example and he's been
a huge part of the book as well so
um it is by far the coolest piece of
material both in video form and written
form
there is no book that compares to to
this book and i don't think there are
any movie or videos that are comparing
to these videos so
um i am super thankful to have the
opportunity to
spend so much time making such high
quality material because usually the
material i produce
even though it often is better than
those around
it it's pretty quick like i don't really
have to spend that much time polishing
it or making it nicer
or but the other kind of side effect is
i can't go very deep
into complex topics so
i really appreciate the opportunity to
be doing that
and i hope the outcome is something
everyone will enjoy because i
this has been so cool and and just like
i've learned so much doing it
so anyway um stay tuned more stuff to
come
for sure uh and then after the normal
hours from scratch series
uh we are pretty much for sure going
back
to the python plays gta 5 series
so uh stay tuned for those things that
will probably be
2021 but so yeah
that is the hope and the dream is to
return back to that
and just have some fun again with that
series because both me and daniel which
is that that's where we met
right daniel came in around that time um
we've learned so much since since that
time
uh that it'll be really cool to see what
we can do on a kind of revisit
revisiting of that topic but anyway um
that's all if you've got further
questions comments whatever feel free to
leave them below if you want to get the
book
again the full the whole book is
available we're missing
images uh there are some images uh but
we're still missing some images but the
actual content the explanation the code
is all there we're covering a full
forward pass backward pass all the
optimization
actually training a neural network um
everything is there including using your
own data we end up at the end we're
using the
not mnist it's the fashion mnist data
set so something a little different
but yeah from training testing you know
doing validation and testing sets and
adding in your own data how to kind of
format that all those kinds of things
everything from scratch it is the
coolest thing
um that i know of i don't know of a
cooler book
so definitely check it out if you can
otherwise stay tuned for the videos
uh other than that i'll see you guys
later
you